Miley Cyrus has been sued for copyright  infringement for posting a photo of  herself to Instagram this is exactly  what happened to Dua Lipa Ariana Grande  and Justin Bieber who all got sued for  posting photos of themselves because  they didn't own the copyright just  because you're the subject of a  photograph doesn't mean that you own the  underlying copyright and that list of  celebrities is no coincidence because  the same photographer took all of those  photos and sued all of those celebrities  Robert Barbera has taken photos of  Justin Bieber Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and  Miley Cyrus and they just couldn't  resist posting those great photographs  of themselves to Instagram and while  it's counter-intuitive that you can be  in a photograph but not own the  copyright this lawsuit like all of those  other lawsuits is probably going to be a  slam dunk for Barbera who's probably  going to get a nice little payday  because these celebrities don't  understand copyright law